Jeff Deverett, Film Producer, Entrepreneur,
Writer, Director: Independent filmmakers don't
even know about this stuff. This is stuff that's
totally foreign that they would never get around
to. They don't have enough time to get around to
it, let alone to do it even if they knew about it.
Film Courage:
What's different about the pitching process
with Netflix now versus prior years, 2015 2014?
Jeff: Like I said before it's bigger company
so they generally they generally don't take
pictures that's a different i've done business
with Netflix for three films but I'm not going
to call myself a Netflix expert there are
people who do way more business than I do
especially different types of business like
internally I haven't done any Netflix originals
i've talked to them about it there's a different
department and different style and all that kind
of stuff so I just sort of know what I know
as an outsider and again I'm not I guess I'm
much further ahead than any indie filmmaker
who hasn't done any business with them but
like I feel like I'm not that qualified to talk
about it but I guess more so than others but the
pitching what makes it different it's just back
then they took pitches they just don't take them
they don't have the time or the interest unless
it's it's done through the right channels which
is agents or distributors so it's you're basically
locked out now how are your pitches different now
knowing that they're a bigger company they have
less time they have so many people trying to get
into that front door yeah my pitches to everybody
not just Netflix anybody who I'm dealing with are
shorter and more concise and right to the point
because of lack of time and they hear so much
so I get right down to it one it's almost a log
line like here's the movie here's what it's about
and here's the audience and here's how we're
going to go after that audience and here's
what I'm going to bring to the table as a
result here's the marketing I'm going to do
and it's like I say I try to keep it to five
minutes and then the rest is hopefully questions
but that's all you really need you can get to I
could do it in 20 probably 30 seconds but I spread
it out just a little bit so I'm not talking too
fast but yeah back then I was pitching as I said
in the last video I would do 20 to 30 minutes
for a pitch tell them about the story tell them
about this the actors how we're going to shoot and
they don't care nobody cares about that stuff just
make a darn good movie tell us who the audience is
and and deliver so if I was at Netflix you've just
just pitched me what are my questions going to be
to you or am I just sending you out the door thank
you very much we'll look it over no but remember
I'm not going to get a pitch for something that
I'm unless it's a Netflix original and and in
that case I'm sort of just telling them the idea
and that's more about the script because they're
just basically going to buy the script and maybe
hire me to make the film or maybe just take
the script and make it internally with one
of their crews so potentially I could be
hired on maybe just direct or something
and then we would talk it's all artistic it's not
about audience anymore because they're going to
own the film they'll control that they'll bring
all that to the table so the other flip side is
pitching a finished film you've already finished
the film so you don't have to talk about the
story or this or that so back then I would do
that now I don't talk about any of that because
here's the film like just watch the film I don't
have to tell you what like that's why I say it's
one sentence about the log line but but here's the
film you either want it or you don't want it based
on the movie itself so they're hearing the log
line they're taking the materials maybe they'll
they're watching it and then they'll watch
the movie for sure no no unlike distributors
they'll definitely watch the movie no they
don't watch every movie they'll watch the
first 10 minutes and if they like it then they'll
watch the next 10 minutes and hopefully they get
through the whole thing right to make sure that
it's okay but the reason that they'd be interested
is because there's a audience attached to it
because there's like I say if I had 10 seconds
to pitch Netflix on and that's all you got right
maybe I should suggest this to Netflix give every
indie filmmaker 10 seconds speed pitching
right or 20 seconds or something like that
I wouldn't even tell them the name of the film
all I’d say is I have 2 million viewers on youtube
who've already seen it and want to see it on
Netflix that's the pitch hopefully that's the case
and they'd say oh by the way what's the name of
the film you sure you got the 2 million prove to
us she got the 2 million let's see it did you
dig it did you do something that's the pitch
the film matters but the audience matters more can
we reenact the pitch that you did for your last
movie sure to Netflix how did you let's suppose
I'm the person on the other side of the desk great
to see you have a seat can you get them some water
coffee great thank you no that didn't even happen
that happens in the long run they validate
your bathroom that's happens in the lobby
they have a nice station in the lobby go
get yourself a drink a coffee whatever
and no when we get up to the meeting room
let's get right into it all right so the
pitch was very simple it was like I want to make
another the the olympics are coming in two years
I believe that we did well with our first movie
with full out and I would like to make another
gymnastics movie similar to that because with the
olympics coming we know that women's gymnastics is
a big thing in an olympic year and you've already
developed that audience with the first movie would
you be interested in having another one and i've
already got a story and I got an idea of who we
would do it with it would be very similar to the
first one but a completely different storyline but
it would engage the exact same audience and
I think that it would be the timing would
be good to deliver it then during that olympic
year similar to what we did with the first one
and what was their response I like it we
like it what tell me more and the more right
there in the meeting okay the answer was yeah
that's a good idea okay what are you thinking
I'm thinking we should do this this storyline
I know it came a minute i've got this gymnast
who who did this and I think it'd make a really
good story and instead of doing hip-hop dancing
I want to do break dancing in this one so similar
type of thing with two characters that meet but
let's go into the break world because it's really
cool these days and the music is really good and I
think that'll resonate okay great idea when when
you wanted to shoot it blah blah blah I'm gonna
shoot it then when would you deliver okay we would
need it by here by this time and then the number
then how much would you be willing to pay and
then we get into that and that takes a minute
or two no but they also by the way they're sitting
with an ipad and they're saying oh let's see what
did fallout 1 do yeah okay the numbers look pretty
good all right let's talk about the next one they
would actually give you that number oh no they
don't tell you they they're looking at their
ipad they're not telling you they're saying yeah
okay looks okay we're good we're good to go next
I say can you share the not can you turn the
ipad around I want to see the numbers no we
don't do that it would be really good I i put
some of my heart and soul into it can't you just
throw me a bone here tease me give me one number
sorry we don't do that we don't do that and they
don't do that that's their proprietary information
and that's the way it works but luckily the
numbers were good on that iPad otherwise the
conversation would have been really short and so
this was less than a 10-minute meeting this last
one the substance was 10 minutes there might have
been five minutes of pleasantries okay how are
you doing how's the golf game nice office whatever
yeah but yeah yeah it took about 10 minutes but
there was one other piece of business in that
movie because I was wanting to do a renewal on the
first one too it was coming up for renewal and so
we were talking about both the renewal and the
next one I see okay yeah and the numbers were
good so both happened the renewal and the the
new one so that works in your favor obviously
so you go in there with good numbers and then you
pitch them something else it's everything if the
numbers aren't good it's over it's over before
it starts yeah there's nothing to talk about
getting the first one is the tough one because
you don't have any numbers the second one if
your numbers are good it's real easy meeting and
if your numbers are bad it's a very tough meeting
you got to explain why your numbers are going
to be better the next time around if they're
even interested to hear it but the subject matter
is super niche I know that audience really well
i've done tons of marketing to it I they know I'm
connected to it they know that I know how to get
to that audience and create viewership there so
because i've already done the marketing and now
even more so we're gonna like and I explain
what we're gonna do in addition to this with
the dance world that we didn't do last time
so that's music to their ears and hopefully
it works and hopefully they get new subscribers
as a result of it I want them to be successful
because if they're successful then hopefully
they greenlight something else I'm gonna do
and that's just supporting their efforts how are
you sharing your ideas for marketing the film that
you're pitching so with Netflix or with everybody
let's see for this for this case yeah Netflix
oh I'm telling them straight up I'm saying okay
we're going to start with the gymnastics the USA
gymnastics which is their network of all the gyms
across the united states and the coaches so we're
gonna we're gonna get an endorsement from them I
had a special olympian in there so we're going to
special olympics we're getting their endorsement
meaning they'll put the message out to all of
their athletes and families of which they have
many we I'm dealing with the dance magazine and
dance world so there's all kinds of dance tons
of dance clubs and studios and so I'm advertising
through them I'm doing both paid advertising
and social media and then we're doing some
a whole bunch of of web-based stuff with one
of our key dancers so the main breakdancer in
the movie is a world-renowned breakdancer and so
she did interactive stuff that we had all planned
pre-planned as part of the promotion and so they
don't know anything about the breaking world
I didn't know much about it either I learned
about it obviously but so as I explained it to
them and they looked up who this is and what
these communities are and how to get to them
and everything like that and that's probably a
good audience for them and they probably have a
lot of that audience already but it's interesting
for for them to hear about it so these are things
that you're explaining not in a ton of detail
just enough to tweak their interests and make
them see that you're going to do some hard work
and really engage try to engage an audience and
that's for everybody's benefit primarily for the
benefit of my movie because I want audience on it
by the way this is before they say yes right so
I'm doing this anyways regardless of whether they
say yes I'm doing because I want to be successful
with my movie so if they don't say yes maybe I
take it to apple tv and pitch them the same thing
or to Hulu or something like that which by the way
did so because you're waiting six weeks you're not
sitting there with your thumb up your butt waiting
for an answer you're pitching everybody because
you you hope that somebody comes through and you
hope it's the one you want but it's kind of like
applying for for lack of a better example college
you don't apply to one you apply to one that's
a disaster unless you're pretty darn sure you're
gonna get in you apply to ten or and and you hope
that you're just hedging your bets a little bit
so the long line is equally important as how
you'll market to your audience and who your market
who your audience is it sounds like neither is
more important than the other you've got to have
both the log line is just for pitching everybody
on their platform doesn't put just a log line they
put a synopsis you go into Netflix and you see
a three or four sentence synopsis on every film
so the log line is just when you're pitching
it's the yellow it's what the people call the
elevator pitch thing you got three floors in
an elevator and you better get it out quickly
so you just get a log line in there that
sort of captures what the movie's about
and then as soon as you capture their attention
then they might ask you more details and you can
go into a little bit more detail but I find by the
way I find that filmmakers the big mistake they
make in pitching and they do this all the time
when I'm consulting with them is they talk way too
much about the story we all know story elements
we get it we know genres I know pretty well all
of them so just like tell me the details because I
say to them this is the irony so they're paying me
for their time they might book an hour right and
they're paying for that and they start going into
the story and I say no no no let me stop here
for a second I don't want you wasting your time
your paid time telling me your story I get it I
get the audience I get who you're talking about
I don't need the details of the story I'm sure
it's great I'm sure it's unique let's get into the
substance the substantive stuff which is the
marketing and the distribution all that kind of
stuff because don't take 20 minutes to tell
me your story because they would otherwise
because they're so engaged in their story and
it's not about the story it's obviously at the
end of the day when you make the movies about
the story but it's not about the story at that
at that stage that's why I was wondering is how
important it sounds like then the synopsis or log
line whatever it is you're going off to pitch them
is equally important as who's your demographic
who how are you getting to them well think
about it like you're sitting there you're
Netflix buyer right I'm saying to you
I'm going after the dance world in the
gymnastics world okay as long as I have a decent
story where there's characters and character arcs
and development and everything like that the
question they need to ask is how many dance
routines am I going to have how many gymnastics
routines am I going to have oh yeah what's the
main character and what's their relationship but
how many big production scenes are going to like
kids want to see the gymnastics and the dance
that's what they really want to see and as long
as it's not a disaster the rest of it it's got to
have a story that weaves through and a compelling
story line and like I say character accent
everything like that but but if you have all
that and you don't have good production like you
don't have any dance sequences or or gymnastics
competitions or something like that it's not
going to be a good movie for that audience
so that's really what if you understand who your
audience is and I understand my audience because I
make movies for them then I'm saying to Netflix
this is what my audience wants to see and they
understand that because they have shared audience
and they understand what audiences like to see
fame tv show fame yeah for sure all of the dance
routines interwoven they had they had cheer they
had cheer on there that sure was the series that
they did about cheerleading so they understand
that market really well but now that's in the
department that acquires that's the licensing side
so that's who I'm pitching to is they're going
to acquire the movie right if you're pitching
to Netflix originals where you're talking story
this pitch might be totally different it might be
way more about story character art plot points all
this kind of stuff they're going to get more into
the artistic side of it because they're going to
be making the movie with you so they want to see
some of the artistic vision but this is you're
making a movie and you're going to tell them why
it's marketable and you're hopefully going to make
a good movie that they're going to buy they're not
involved at all artistically so it's a sort of a
different style altogether it's not sort of it is
it is you're not talking creatives with them
you're talking about audience that you're going to
resonate with when you deliver this finished film
the film's done they have no say in it because
it's you can't change it it's over whereas
in the other side the Netflix original it's
nothing's happened yet they can change everything
and you would have a broader audience for this
because I'm thinking of like the tv show dance
moms I believe i've never actually watched it
just seen trailers but you have not only the the
kids in the in the thing that are the dancing the
dancers sorry but you also have the the mom so
you have a much wider you have parents and you
have their kids oh yeah and I just told you two
components I went break dancing and gymnastics of
course there's there's lots of ancillary stuff and
everything yeah no I have a whole marketing plan
I just didn't want to spend too much time on this
interview talking about it but we could go into a
lot more detail about like all the components of
what we did I did a whole bunch of promotions too
like for example i'll just give you one we shot
that particular movie we shot in Oklahoma city
at the university of Oklahoma with the Oklahoma
Sooners it's about one of their gymnasts and
it's shot on location there so I did a huge
promotion in Oklahoma city with pizza hut
and I created a lot of awareness by doing a pizza
top box topper that goes out to I don't know 50
000 pizzas they sell in whatever period it was
so that the local audience because the girl's
wearing a Oklahoma Sooners outfit that's the key
art so everybody in Oklahoma city knows who the
Sooners are you might not know but everybody
there does from seeing your movie yeah okay so
so that's local stuff yeah we also did lots of
television publicity spots there we got a lot of
ads and not ads but we got a lot of spots on local
editorial public they were all interested that a
movie was being shot on location about a true
story about one of their gymnasts so we got lots
and lots of that which I used in that market more
so I'm not going to use that nationally because
it doesn't resonate but locally it resonates
really well so but the Netflix of the world
understand all that stuff because their business
is engaging audiences so they get something like
some Kansas City reporter doing a story of Brennan
Dowell which is what happened is great in Kansas
City and that's good and what does that mean to
Netflix it's one tiny component of their entire
base but it's better than nothing and maybe they
can sign up ten a thousand more subscribers there
in that marketplace based on that maybe this is
micromanaging running a business so and building
your audience no those are great details and
I love that and I love that you would think of
pizza hut maybe that's something that but families
are going to be ordering pizza and who's going to
want to see it the pizza hut thing first of all
there's I should have brought it there's a whole
flyer that we printed with a with a a discount on
watching the movie you get a so the reason pizza
hut was in was so the the win-win was they stuck
this flyer it was like a postcard size thing of
the graphic and I'm saying new movie available
on the following platforms and it's like six
transactional platforms and then the flip side is
special promotion from pizza hut 50 off in this
market with this pizza and here's the code and
you stick it in and you get it for 30 days you can
watch the movie for half price with the purchase
of this pizza so it's a win-win but hold on that
was just one that's one promotion I do tons
of those and and pizza hut was just one of the
there's 10 pizza chains so I pitched like five of
them not just pizza hut I wanted pizza hut but if
pizza had said no maybe it was dominoes you're
pitching everybody but like I say I spend way
more time marketing than I do on making movies
way more time that's the kind of stuff you're
talking about and to kind of go back to what
I was talking about before filmmakers first
of all don't even know about this kind of stuff
secondly what filmmaker wants to do that film like
talking to 10 pizza joints to figure out a local
pizza promotion you don't want to do that you
want to make movies studios have all this built in
they just take for granted all that kind of stuff
independent filmmakers don't even know about this
stuff this is stuff that's totally foreign that
they would never get around to they don't have
enough time to get around to it let alone to do
it even if they knew about it like I'm telling you
like to me this is like a no-brainer I'm talking
about it it's like that's nothing compared I can
tell you some way more niche stuff than that like
that is a pretty big promotion there's stuff
that's even smaller and you're saying wow
that's interesting and I'm thinking that's not
that interesting that's kind of what you do
how are you getting a mom and
daughter in Chicago to care about
a gymnast from Oklahoma because hopefully
the daughter's taking gymnastics or dance
and hopefully she's connected to a gymnastics
or a dance club where her coach says hey this
new movie came out it's really nice family fair
I think you and your family would enjoy it and
potentially a little bit of social media
where we're targeting maybe facebook ads that
target to that depends on how old the daughter
is maybe she's 12 that's our core audience for
that kind of movie and maybe they facebook has all
these analytics and everything so that's part of
it but yeah we're we're reaching out a different
the more direct stuff is through the clubs
and we send we send the clubs every club got sent
a postcard kind of similar to what I was talking
about every club to the coach when we did the
first one if it wasn't the pandemic because the
clubs were closed and the first one we sent a
poster to every club and asked them to hang the
poster a sign poster was a nice really nice poster
so that was a nice sort of thing to put in their
lobby so and that creates awareness and then of
course we have a website which they go to and get
details and that type of thing and that's generic
marketing it's specific to that audience but this
is what I'm talking about like there's so much
involved in marketing when you do marketing for
a living that's not that special what I just said
and it's special but not that special but when you
do filmmaking all of a sudden marketing is like
holy smokes I didn't even know about this stuff
like this is this is really good like I i
didn't even know you could do that kind of stuff
yeah there's a creativity in what you're telling
me because there's different things you can plug
in here and it's a challenge it doesn't sound
that easy there's creativity in knowing what to do
and then there's execution and actually doing
it which is a lot of work if that stuff doesn't
come overnight you gotta work it and you gotta
negotiate it and contract it and deliver and
print and do all this kind of stuff but when
it works it you can get really good results.